(audience chattering)
- Good morning, everybody.
And if you don't have
your headphones on yet,
you might wanna put 'em
on if you can't hear me
from where you are sitting
up on the front row.
But welcome, welcome.
I'm Alex. I'm a member of technical staff
and Anthropic and I'm joined here by,
- Nadine.
Hi, I'm Nadine. Nice to meet you all.
- Both members of technical staff here.
And we're here to tell you about some
of the really cool research findings
that we've recently published at Anthropic
on Long Horizon coding agents.
We'd really love for
you to kind of consider
a couple of the lessons
that we ourselves learned
that we're here to share.
One of those being that we're
still the thinkers, right,
and that's why I'm
wearing this thinking cap.
We're still the thinkers,
even though the agents can
do a lot of the work for us.
That's one of the lessons.
That's kind of the societal
impacts lesson, if you will.
And then the second one
is the technical learnings
that we're here to share.
- Yeah, so if you're
here at re:Invent Live,
then you might have
actually seen our demo live
in the Anthropics booth,
specifically in the Claude
Keeps Building booth,
in which Claude is building
a project management tool
that we're calling Canopy
and it's taking in feature requests
from attendees like yourself
to continuing to iterate on
the minimum viable product.
And so, this is all being
hosted on AWS infrastructure,
specifically AgentCore Runtime.
And we'll be going in detail
about the architecture
a little bit later on.
But to get started, we just wanna give you
a little bit of context
on why this is important
and the lessons that we learned
along the way to reach this point.
- Yeah.
So let's jam with a silent
disco and get into it.
So really, what are long horizon agents?
What are we really talking about here?
So we've been thinking
about this in terms of
what are the ways that we can teach AI
to handle the quote
unquote, "boring parts."
And so when we talk about boring parts,
it's very much a tongue in cheek phrase.
We, you know, how many of you here
are developers in the room?
Quite a few of you. Awesome, right?
So, if you think about, you know,
the development workflow, we
really want to encourage us
to continue to be the thinkers in the room
while allowing the AI
to do some of the things
that maybe aren't as exciting.
We'll talk about that here soon.
But really what we want to do here
are the lessons from building agents
that work across these many sessions.
And that's going to be
the technical aspect of this presentation.
- So let me ground this
in developer reality.
So as you might all know, your
Monday plan might start off,
you have a few features
or maybe like a pretty optimistic one
where you wanna work on
updating some API documentation,
maybe writing some unit
tests for edge cases,
maybe fixing a bug,
and then finally, if you have the time,
work on some sort of innovative feature
that you've been wanting
to get to for a long time.
But then reality strikes or hits.
And what ends up happening
is the quick sync
that was meant to take 15 minutes
might have become a 45
minute heated debate
about the roadmap, or a Sev1 comms
and you have to fix some
sort of production bug.
Or there's a 47 message slack thread
that requires your input to continue.
And so by the time you actually get
to opening your IDE and
working, it's already 4:30.
So basically what we were looking to solve
and what we were looking to,
what we were questioning was whether AI
or LLMs specifically could handle
some of this more mechanical
or repetitive implementation and work,
and humans can focus
on the judgment calls.
And I wanna be very clear,
we're not saying this is
like a fix for everything.
This is not gonna solve all your problems,
won't like free up all your time.
What we're saying is that
we've seen a specific,
we've seen specific trends
and specific things that work
for specific types of tasks
and we wanna share those
learnings with you today.
So yeah, that's sort of what our focus is.
And to get that started,
there's a specific challenge
that we wanna describe
and that's the fact that LLMs
have a fundamental limitation.
So yeah, thank you.
As you all might know,
LLMs are forgetful, right?
So they're unable to
keep a persistent memory
from session to session.
So while in theory, this new
pair programmer might be great
because they love to write
tests, which is awesome,
they never complain about
updating documentation,
which is also great
and they follow your
coding standards to the T,
they might forget where they
left off session to session.
And that might seem like a problem,
like a problem that we wanna solve.
But what we've seen is, while
this is great, for example,
for quick tasks where you have a function,
you ask Claude to write a
function and it finishes it
and you're done,
for longer projects where
it might be 200 features
that run over hours and maybe days,
this feels like it would be a problem.
What we've discovered,
and this might be a
little counterintuitive,
is that forgetting isn't
necessarily a bad thing
because forgetting means that the model
isn't picking up bad habits,
it's not sort of reinforcing
these incorrect assumptions
and it's able to
generally be more focused.
So if we solve for this memory externally
rather than through the model,
then forgetting becomes
a feature, not a bug.
And that's what we're talking about today.
- Yeah.
And so let's ground this
in the reality, right?
So if we think of us humans,
it takes quite a while for us
to get back into flow
If we get distracted.
You know, some research has shown that
it can take 20 minutes for somebody
to get back into flow as a developer.
I've certainly been there.
If you think about us here
at Vegas and you know,
we go out and party and
we come back the next day,
it might take actually quite a bit longer.
It might take, you know, an hour
before you're back in flow the next day.
With the agents they really can do this
very, very quickly, right?
They can come back into flow very quickly.
But there is a fundamental problem
and that's the context, right?
So while we as humans
take longer than agents
to get into kind of the next session,
the issue for the agents
is, as Nadine was saying,
how do we,
when the agent wakes up,
how does it know what to do next, right?
And so each new session
begins with no real memory
of what came before and
that's both a superpower
and a bit of a flaw too, right?
So really, we're talking about how do we
imbue the agent from session to session
with the correct context
so that it can continue
building where it left off.
- Yeah.
And so this changes sort of how we think
of the human AI division of labor
and we wanted to show you
what we found to be effective.
So what we've looked at is that
the human would be in charge
of creating the vision
or designing the vision
and the requirements and
setting the standards
and the constraints
and actually making the
architectural decisions
and then reviewing the
outputs of the models.
And then the models, the AI builders
or more specifically the LLM builders,
will be implementing those features
following that vision or the guidance.
And then the test will
be done within the like,
against the criteria that you've set
and the documentation
will be constantly updated
as it works, which is really great.
And then it will basically
iterate on the feedback
that you are providing it.
And a key word here is,
that I wanna emphasize is constraints.
So you will have a sort of standards file
and this should be read only to the agent.
So the agent shouldn't be allowed to go in
and edit your style or edit
your architectural decisions.
The way I like to think of it is,
you are the architect and the AI
or the LLM is sort of the builder
that's following the
blueprint that you designed.
So yeah.
- So let's talk about what environment
as memory really looks like.
And this is something that
we're going to show you
in a live demonstration
here in a few minutes.
So we're not just gonna talk
off the slides I promise.
But really, you know,
there are things that
we have to consider when we
think about the environment.
One of those things is
the feature list, right?
So interestingly, we've discovered that
if we have the agent
build up the feature list
from a specification,
this is kind of a form
of specification driven development.
You've probably heard this before,
both as developers and in the AI space.
It's almost like, you know,
all the old things are new again,
we have the agent build up a feature list
and that feature list is a JSON file.
And again, the reason why it's a JSON file
and not a markdown file is
that we've discovered that
if we have it create a JSON file,
it's actually less likely
to write to that file.
If we give it instructions to do that
than if we had a read me
file, a markdown file.
If we have a markdown file,
it's more likely to edit it
and we don't want it to do
that once it has come up
with the initial specification.
So that's very important.
As Nadine was saying,
we also want the agent
on every subsequent session
to have the same standards
as it had in the previous session.
So we have a Standards MD
file that we give the agent
with the standards of
whatever development team
that you are on, right?
There's also a Claude Progress MD file
and the Claude Progress MD file is another
sort of piece of information
that we give the agent
at the beginning of the
session so that the new session
knows where the previous session left off.
That's actually joined
up with Git commits.
So we as developers know
what that's like, right?
If we write good commits,
next developers that come
and look at the code base can
look at the commit history
that previous developers have
actually added to the code base, right?
And we are learning that
if we give the agents
these same sort of primitives if you will,
the agents do a better job.
They kind of think like
us, they work like us.
Probably not a surprise
because we train them right,
even though it's on the
knowledge of the internet.
And then finally there is an init.sh file.
And it turns out
that this is actually
quite important as well
because when the agent
starts a new session,
we want the agent to start
the dev server, right?
We want the agent to
look at the environment.
There are sort of,
some things that are quite
deterministic, right?
And those deterministic things
go into that init.sh file.
So there's the non-deterministic nature
of what the agent will actually do,
but there is the deterministic part
of actually getting that
environment started on each session
and started in a very repeatable
and deterministic way.
So that's what the init.sh file is about.
And so with that, sorry, I'm
getting a little bit excited
as you can probably tell
'cause this is a lot of fun,
the loop that never breaks, right?
So I was talking about kind of,
the fundamentals of each environment,
but what actually happens
when the session starts?
When the session starts,
there's essentially this agentic loop.
If you're familiar with, you know,
any of the work that we've done
and any of the talks we've
done about what agents are,
agents are nothing more than an LLM,
it's environment, its tools
and running in a loop
running continuously, right?
So the loop that never
breaks pretty much, you know,
from each iteration to each iteration,
the agent is going to look
at its environment first.
It's always going to look
at what happened before
and what environment is it working within.
It's then going to run the
test suite to make sure that
the things that happened
in the previous session
are still repeatable in the next session.
Probably quite familiar to the work
that we do as developers.
If you're a developer, you know
that you gotta run the tests
to make sure that they still pass
from iteration to iteration,
that no new regressions have occurred.
So this is why we have the agent
actually create a test suite and run it
every time that the session starts.
So there's some basic
verification that it does.
After it's completed the verification,
we actually go in and have the agent
pick up the next available feature
to have the agent start
working on that feature.
As it's working on that feature,
it's also continuing to run the tests.
And there's some interesting insights here
that we'll share about, you
know, what we found so far,
whether it should be a
single agent, you know,
two agents or multiple agents.
We'll talk about that here pretty soon.
So the agent then continues to build,
it continues to implement the feature
and this is something we'll
show you in real time here.
And then it's gonna again,
test like a human and commit its work
because at the end of the
day we really want the agent
to continue to write to the history.
We want it to write the
sort of the progress
of the work that it has done.
Excuse me, I need some water.
See this is why I'm
human and not an agent.
Anyway.
So it will write the commits
and it will write the progress
and then eventually, the
next session will pick up
and look at that history
and be able to kind of get started again.
- Yeah.
And this loop sort of emerged
from the learnings that we had.
So we wanted to like briefly explain
to you the breakthroughs
that we had moving
from one-shotting to incremental progress.
Initially, the approach we
worked with, and by yesterday,
I mean like around a month ago,
what we were working with is,
we had an agent that tries to
implement everything at once.
And we noticed that there
was a bit of an issue
with the context running out mid feature,
which was not ideal.
And we also like realized
that the model sometimes
declared victory a bit too early.
It was quite smart.
So sometimes it gamed
its own success criteria
and reward hacked.
So we noticed that we also,
so like as Alex mentioned,
we noticed that we had
to explicitly tell it
that it was unacceptable
to remove or edit tests
to make them pass.
And then what we decided to do
and what we found most effective
and what we'll be showing you today
and we've been showing at the demos,
yeah,
is that basically we ideally
work on one feature at a time
and this helps with what we mentioned
with the context window running out.
And then another thing is that
we leave the environment in a clean state.
So we're using the commits as memory,
but we're leaving the actual
environment clean every time.
It starts off with a new feature
and the most important thing
is that it tests end to end
like a human would.
So we actually give it the
ability to use browser automation
so it can check the UI
and work through the fixes
and the features to see that
they're actually working
and not just working in theory,
and this might not sound
sort of revolutionary,
and it seems sort of like
what a good engineer would
do from a day to day,
but what we were working on,
was trying to explicitly encode this
and allow the agent to
work in this manner.
So yeah.
- Yeah and that's
actually by design, right?
We in our research have found that
the closer we actually mimic
the developer workflow,
the better the agent does.
So precisely what Nadine
was talking about.
I will go further and
talk a little bit more
about this 200 feature
manifesto in a moment.
But I want to go back to some of
what Nadine was talking about
when she was talking about the
specification and the tests.
So we have the agent write the tests
as it continues to build.
And what we've discovered as well,
even just building the demo
for the booth at booth A10,
please come and check it out,
and we'll show you some
of that today as well,
is that if the agent is asked
to write individual tests,
what happens is, as the time
approaches for the agent
to complete its work,
it will actually run into
these anxiety attacks.
Like, quite literally
you'll see in the logs,
it's saying hey, we
are running out of time
so we better finish this quickly
and starts to reward hack
as Nadine was talking about.
And so some of the things
that you ought to consider
when you are building
this kind of stuff is,
how do you prevent those reward hacks
and what are some of the ways
that that can be resolved?
And as Nadine was saying,
if we think about the agent
as sort of a junior to
mid-level developer,
then we really arrive at this idea
of a 200 feature manifesto, if you will.
And it's a little bit of
work upfront, you know.
Building a specification,
which we'll actually
show you an example of
that has enough details for
the agent to do the work well,
for the agent to write tests
is not an easy task upfront,
but it pays dividends in the end, right?
If you start with a specification
that the agent can follow quite closely
but still have enough capability
to act non deterministically
and explore different paths,
that's kind of the holy grail.
So what winds up happening is that,
we go from a specification
which is a markdown file
that we as humans write into
this JSON sort of format
that the agent can then
or is less likely to edit,
which we don't want the
agent to modify this.
We want the agent to use
the JSON file specification
and mark tests as passing
as it continues to do its
work from session to session.
And so that's kind of the
interesting thing here.
This changes how developers
spend their time.
- Yeah.
So we wanted to give you a bit of an idea
of what this model would
look like in practice
and how this would change
for developers like yourself.
So we're going from,
originally you'd be
writing the code yourself,
you're debugging manually,
you're documenting afterwards if at all,
and you're probably context
switching between tasks
as you have a lot of different
fixes at different times.
And the model that we're
envisioning for after is that,
you're spending more of your time
defining these requirements
for the LLM to follow
like I mentioned earlier.
You're also reviewing the
AI's like test results
rather than fully debugging manually
and making sure that they're correct
and following what you're expecting.
And then, the really nice
thing is the documentation
is generated as the LLM or AI is working
because this is encoded into the workflow
and the way that it's working.
And the last thing is that the
agent is what's maintaining
its progress notes of how it's working.
And what we found is like
you might be wondering
if this is faster overall or if it's not.
For us from what we found is
that oftentimes it is faster
but it's faster for a very
well specified project.
So it really depends on for you,
how your specification,
the domain you're in and your
tolerance for review cycles.
And yeah, so we wanted
to be a bit clear about
what becomes possible and like
where the limitations are.
So yeah, so to start what, it's improving,
so I've mentioned this a lot of times
'cause this is really important to me,
but the tests are written
for every feature by default,
which is awesome because then
you have a lot of test
coverage which we found
when we were doing the demos.
So that's done by default.
And then the other thing is,
the documentation is
updated for every session.
So it's constantly up to date
and it's constantly accurate.
And then the last thing is that,
it's consistent with your coding style,
which is really great because
like I mentioned earlier,
it's following your standards
and your style almost religiously.
But there are some limitations
that we wanted to highlight.
So one of the main ones
and one that you're probably
aware of is the vision gaps.
So the models might not be the best at
seeing every single visual bug.
So oftentimes, it needs your judgment
and that's why we're saying
this is like a collaborative
sort of model to check and find these bugs
and these features and make
those requests sort of like
how we're doing live in
the demo at the booth.
And then the other thing
is that automation,
like browser automations
like Puppeteer or Playwright,
oftentimes can't see native alerts,
which is something you should be aware of.
And the other thing is
that like I mentioned
and like we iterate a lot,
this is not replacing human review,
it's not sort of a fire
and forget sort of model.
It's one that you would
need to like verify
before it goes fully in production.
So yeah, that's sort of what
we wanted to emphasize today,
what's possible and the limitations there.
- Yeah.
And let's ground this in reality,
and this is gonna be the
preamble to the actual demo.
So this is the architecture
that we implemented
for the demo booth and what
we're gonna show here today.
And so, you can see that,
hopefully this works.
I'm trying to do the
laser pointer thing maybe.
No, it's not gonna be that
great on a white background
but hopefully it'll work.
Yeah, so there are three major components
to this architecture,
really four if you will.
The first is the list of GitHub issues.
And we think of the GitHub
issues as kind of the backlog
for the agent to work on the MVP first
and all the subsequent
issues that are added.
And because we're gonna do
this in a public repository,
we're actually going
to very happily ask you
to features and have the agent build them.
This is going to be running
over the next couple of days.
So really our goal is to,
by the end of re:Invent,
have an application
that's quite functional.
It already is.
Just over the last two days,
you'll see what we've built.
And so GitHub issues is
one of the components.
I mentioned that there are four.
GitHub actions as well.
So the GitHub actions that
we've written is essentially,
you can think of that as just the CICD
that we're all very happily
familiar with, right?
And so what happens is,
there's an issue puller
that basically sits there
and on a cron job, essentially
on a scheduled basis,
looks at the GitHub issues
that are in that GitHub repository
and picks up new issues to work on.
And the way that we do that
is we, we've kind of come up
with a way to allow folks
to vote on the issues
and also for some of us,
myself, Nadine and Philly
at the booth, to actually approve issues
that could be worked on by
the agent using reactions.
So there's a thumbs up emoji for voting.
So whenever any of you add a feature,
you can also come in and
vote for that feature,
we'll show you that in a moment
and then you know, we'll
approve those features
if we think they're good to go.
And then those features are
gonna be built by the agent.
And that brings us to
the AgentCore Runtime.
So we think of the AgentCore
Runtime in this architecture
as kind of the infrastructure provision
and infrastructure orchestration piece.
We initially started by
thinking about building this
with ECS and managing all
of our own infrastructure.
And that could have been
something we could do,
but we only had about three weeks
and we thought what can
kind of accelerate our work.
And AgentCore Runtime actually turned
out to be a great choice.
There are some interesting caveats there.
So for example, this architecture diagram,
this EFS storage piece,
so initially we were
considering using EFS,
an EFS mounted volume in ECS
container to maintain state.
It turns out that with AgentCore
Runtime we can't do that,
but that's okay, that's
not a bad thing, right?
So we figured out that AgentCore
Runtime is quite ephemeral
and we can't use it with an
EFS volume mounted in it.
Maybe that's coming. I don't know.
I don't speak for AWS.
But what we did instead is we used GitHub,
so a GIT repository as the
state, as the source of truth
instead of an EFS volume.
And that then brings us
to the fourth component,
which is here.
So the Anthropic API on
running on Claude Opus 4.5.
What we did there is,
we've taken the work of
our amazing applied AI team
and our researchers who
built a custom harness
and we built on top of that harness.
And that harness
leverages the Claude code,
Claude Agent SDK recently renamed.
And we use the Claude Opus 4.5 model.
And that's actually quite nice
because if you know anything
about Claude Opus 4.5,
it has much better vision capabilities
than some of our older models.
And so with Claude Opus
4.5 running inside,
essentially running, excuse me,
with the Agent SDK using Claude Opus 4.5
and the runtime and these GitHub Actions,
we're then able to have the agents that,
the agent runtime build new
versions of the application.
Those versions then get
deployed to an S3 bucket
fronted by a CloudFront
distribution for all of us to see.
So that's essentially the
high level architecture
that we're about to show in the demo.
All right. Let's do it.
So this is where things
might get a little exciting.
Let's see what happens.
Right. Live demos.
So maybe Nadine, if you
wanna talk to this feature?
- [Nadine] Yeah.
So I can quickly also show
you just a lot of the issues
that we got requested if
the WiFi's in our favor.
If it's not, then nevermind.
- There it goes.
- [Nadine] Okay, perfect.
So we got throughout the re:Invent,
we got a lot of feature requests
and we've basically been building on them
and once we have proved them,
you can see that the label changes
and becomes when it's
finished, Agent Complete.
When it's building, it's
actually an Agent Building label.
WiFi's a little slow.
So that's not ideal, but you
can check it out in the repo.
And this is an example of a feature
that we actually got at the booth.
So we got a feature
where someone requested
to translate individual
pages into Japanese.
And what you see here is see,
once the agent started building,
it changed its tag to Agent Building.
And this is all done by
the agent, by the way.
This is not us doing it.
And then it starts the session.
And then as it's working, it's
actually taking screenshots.
And this is because we've connected it
to like the Playwright MCP,
and it's able to take those screenshots
and show us what it's seeing
as it's working to debug.
And we'd be looking a bit,
we're gonna dive deep into sort of
what you're seeing in the logs as well
because it helps you see
how the model is reasoning
and what it's thinking
and how it's looking at these
pictures that it's taking.
So yeah. Alex you wanna go ahead?
- Yeah, of course.
Yeah, so we'll jump into
the logs here momentarily,
but I actually want to kind
of come back to one thing
that I forgot to come back to earlier.
So this is the initial
project specification
that we were describing.
And you can see here that
this project specification
has a certain shape to
it, if you will, right?
And you can see that it's XML.
And you might be wondering,
well, why isn't this, you know,
just a standard markdown file.
So, you know, it turns out that
as many of you probably know
that if we add sort of
XML tags, we add structure
and the model is much better at reading
this kind of structure
than just a markdown file.
You can see here that this
defines kind of the overall idea
behind the application as
we were describing earlier.
This is, you know,
essentially a Jira clone
that we call Canopy because, you know,
it's a canopy of trees
and, and features anyway.
And then there was, you know,
a definition for the technology stack.
So like what does the front end
of this application look like?
What does the data layer look like?
So this is like fairly prescriptive
and this is the MVP version of the app
that the agent had built.
And we'll show that to
you here momentarily.
- Yeah.
- Core data,
entities and so on.
- [Nadine] And I wanna add like,
we mentioned a lot about testing.
So also within this
we've sort of given it,
if I can get to it, sort
of testing scenarios.
Okay. It's good.
- It's on the bottom
- It's hard to find it.
- Yeah.
- [Nadine] Okay.
Yeah, here. Like test scenarios.
These aren't for specific features,
but it's sort of just to show
it how it can do the testing
and like we're mentioning,
actually using the browser
automation to do this.
So this is within our build plan.
- [Alex] Yeah.
And so then, what we'd like to show you is
what was initially built.
So if we go here and I
think it was Issue 14.
- 14.
- Yeah.
- [Alex] So we mentioned that this kind
of builds several iterations.
And so let's go back to
the MVP for a second.
And maybe I shouldn't have done this
because the internet is not cooperating.
- [Nadine] Yeah.
(both chuckle)
- [Alex] It'll load eventually,
- [Nadine] Maybe load
the other one as well.
- [Alex] Yeah, good call.
- 36, was it?
- Yes.
- [Alex] Yeah.
All right. Let's see if this works.
There we go.
- Okay.
- [Alex] All right. Good.
We didn't fail in the demo, right.
So this was the initial version
of the application that was built.
This is the MVP based on the
specification that you saw.
And then Nadine was showing you earlier
that there was a feature
that we had the agent build,
which is this, you know,
translate the application into Japanese.
And so what you can see
here is that, first of all,
this is like Issue 36.
We started with Issue 14,
so you can do the math in
terms of the number of features
that were built between then and now.
And then you can see here,
again, as Nadine was mentioning,
that there is a very, very nice audit log
of all the things that
the agent has done, right?
So you can see that there was
a workflow that got started
that the session started,
there's a session ID from
the AgentCore Runtime.
You can see the screenshots that it takes.
One of the folks in the
audience submitted that one,
the admin feature.
He's sitting somewhere in there.
He's on on my team.
So, actually he's my boss,
Ellie.
(both laughing)
Thanks for that one.
And then, you know, sort
of continuing through
and looking at everything
that the state was at
the previous session.
So it's taking screenshots
of kind of the previous state
of the application.
And then eventually it gets
to a point where it like,
actually does new things.
So you can see so many screenshots in here
and you might be wondering to yourself,
well, how the heck is it able
to deal with so much context, right,
if it's taking these screenshots
and it's reading them in
real time as it's working?
With the Agent SDK,
there's built in compaction
and built in context management.
And so, it's able to actually sort of,
work with its own context
and minimize it down
to only what it needs.
So that's important to note there.
And then as we continue,
more and more screenshots,
and then eventually
there's gonna be a commit.
This is like probably 150
screenshots that it took.
Something like that, something wild.
And then eventually, it finds,
it builds the feature, right,
and then it takes screenshots
of the translations.
And then here,
let's see if we can scroll
down a little bit more,
there's the commit and
the work has been done.
The application has been
translated into Japanese.
And so, let's take a look at
what that looks like here.
And of course, I forgot
to put a slash at the end.
And that caused me to not load this page.
So let's do that.
And so here, if we go into settings now,
I believe is where it implemented it.
There you go. Japanese translation, right?
So if I click into that,
we have the app translated into Japanese.
It did this in one session.
So I think that is a
pretty good idea for you
in terms of like what
the workflow looks like.
But Nadine also mentioned logs.
Do you wanna cover some of that?
- [Nadine] Yeah, so if
we look into CloudWatch,
so the awesome thing is because
we're using AgentCore Runtime,
we can actually look
at the CloudWatch logs
and sort of get an idea of
what's going on in the process.
So we can see it starting off here.
So let me just get to the first message.
It started in the background.
Then let me get to it.
It's initializing some things.
It's first starting off by,
let me understand the test structure,
let me read the end of the test of JSON
to see the latest tests.
So it's actually looking
at the previous commits
and understanding what the
previous session was doing.
And then it's like,
let me understand the current
app structure and the file.
So you can basically get insights into
what it's doing with its reasoning.
And also when it does take screenshots,
we also get insights
into what it's seeing.
So if I go somewhere here,
okay, it's a little hard to get,
but basically it will be able to see
and it will make judgements based on that.
Like it's saying let me
update this and this and this
because of the screenshots that it took.
So it's really great to get
basically an insight about
the development process and
what it's going through.
Do you wanna add anything Alex?
- [Alex] No, I think this is probably good
and we can take questions in the end.
So let's continue. Yeah.
- Yes.
- Yeah.
So we covered this,
but just to summarize
everything that you've seen.
- [Nadine] Yeah.
- So as we've mentioned in
kind of the introduction,
every time that a
session starts, you know,
we have the agent set up the environment.
So we have the agent look
at the previous commits,
we have the agent look at
the previous screenshots
that it took, take new
screenshots as it runs the tests,
show the coding agent picking up,
so we've already done that,
but to kind of just going over
what we demonstrated,
it picks up a new feature
to work on in each session.
And then we demonstrated that
it does automated testing.
And one of the things,
one of the key takeaways
that we wanted you to
walk away with is that,
when we ask the agent
to write its own tests,
it's much better to sort of,
to suggest to it that it
should write the tests
for full workflows end to end.
And this is something that
Nadine was covering earlier
because we found that if we,
again, just to reiterate,
if we ask the agent to write tests
for just individual screens,
then that winds up,
ending up in reward hacking, right,
reward hacking behavior.
So ask it to write full tests,
full end-to-end tests for each feature.
And then of course the Git Progress
and sort of the notes that it
takes from session to session,
and that's something we
can show you as well,
where it writes to a file.
And so the compounding effect
of this is that we, you know,
over a period of time this agent builds
a full end-to-end application, right.
And you know, in the first few minutes,
you'll kind of see everything
we've just talked about
where, you know, the agent
sets up the environment,
starts building some of
the core functionality
by 30 minutes, you know.
If you look at the MVP
feature on that repo,
you'll see that it
completed the work actually
in a little bit longer period than that,
but it was about an
hour toward a full MVP.
But every subsequent session
winds up taking a lot less time
because it's already built the MVP,
so now it's just building
the next iteration
and that actually takes
fewer than 30 minutes.
And so this kind of shows the workflow
for building that initial MVP,
but every subsequent feature
actually takes a lot less time.
And so, you know, by our,
in this case, by hour one,
because we've actually constrained,
we initially started with a
full eight hour time horizon,
we've constrained it down to an hour,
eight hours is the limitation
that AgentCore has.
But we decided to narrow
it to kind of demonstrate
how the sessions can be restarted.
So that's one reason that
we took it down to an hour.
But at any rate, you know, if we,
by the end of just a couple of days,
we've had the agent build a
fully featured application
and that's really the compounding effect
that we wanted you to take away.
- And we just wanna emphasize
that we're still learning here
and we're open to your
suggestions and your opinions
and there are a few questions
that we wanna highlight
and that we'd love for you to come
and let us know like your opinion on.
So the first one is something
we're still figuring out.
So is a single general purpose agent best
or should we have you or
your specialized agents
in a more multi-agent architecture?
So this is still something we're
deliberating at the moment.
The way it works is that we have one agent
that's sort of the initializer
and then another agent
that's doing the main coding
and then most of the work.
But yeah, we we're not sure at the moment
if that's the best approach
and that's still
something we're working on
because this is research
and progress, right?
And then another thing is
we are questioning whether
these patterns generalize beyond web apps.
So we've sort of optimized this for
like JSON, TypeScript, React, Node JS,
but we haven't yet had
the chance to experiment
sort of with more data science workflows
or like different domains
and things like that,
or even mobile.
So that's something where
we'd love to explore.
And another thing is that
we don't really know
the full failure modes
and there are probably failure modes
that we haven't discovered yet, right?
So we've been running this for days,
or actually maybe like closer two weeks,
but we haven't been running
this for months, right?
And as you're run things for longer,
there are more things that you discover
like design problems, things like that.
And this is something
we're still looking into
and we'd love for you to feedback to us
so that we can find these issues
and actually work towards
fixing them and optimizing this.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
So let's summarize, you know,
the developer experience challenge
and what every team faces, right?
When we, as developers, spend a lot
of time on repetitive tasks, you know,
there's certain things that
the agent can do for us.
You know, context switching
as we talked about, right,
if we come back and want to get into flow,
it can take 20 minutes or longer.
That's an issue that disrupts
our flow as developers.
Agents don't experience that,
so it's a really, sorry if I
tapped the mic and it was loud.
I apologize.
The context switching can disrupt flow,
but it doesn't do that
for the agents, right?
In fact, it's sort of
a feature, not a bug.
We actually do want it to context switch
while maintaining previous information.
You know, documentation
can be out of date.
These agents will write the documentation
and the tests for you.
So that's really fantastic.
You know, the tests are written
as the agent continues to build
and you can actually verify
that in the repository.
There are specifications, end-to-end specs
that the agent has written
and committed to the repo.
The technical debt can still accumulate.
So this isn't perfect, right?
We did say in the beginning
that this isn't a solved problem
because this is, you know,
Angentic architecture.
Like there's a lot of non-determinism
and so the human is still
very much in the loop.
Remember the thinking cap.
So, you know, we're still the ones
that kind of control the flow.
And I do want you to walk away with that,
that like this isn't about,
you know, full automation.
This is a lot more about
augmenting us as developers
with this fantastic, fantastic tool.
This will help with most of these things,
but it's not gonna, you know,
it's not gonna solve everything
and it's not gonna solve
everything in every case.
So that's very, very important.
- Yeah.
So here's how you can
basically go try this yourself.
So the Claude Agent SDK,
which is what we've been working with,
the framework that we're
working with is out.
You can go use that, you
can go play around with it,
test it and try this out yourself.
All the patterns that we have here
are documented in the blog
post that Alex mentioned
and we'll be sharing a QR
code so you can scan that
and get access to it and read through
and understand our
reasoning in more depth.
And then there's also
an example documentation
in our quick start that you
can also fork and work on.
So you can really get started
today if you wanted to.
And that's what we'd love for you to do.
And one thing we wanna emphasize,
and it's really important even though
it's at the end of the slide,
but it's your standards.
So you're in control.
The agent follows your standard.md.
So if there's something you
don't like about the output,
you can update the standards.
It's not a black box fully.
So yeah, we want you to
really play around with this
and take control.
And if you're at re:Invent,
which you guys are,
we'd love to see you at
the booth and see it.
You can come see it live
or even ask us more
questions if you would like.
Yeah.
- Yeah, and with that, just a
couple of the core takeaways
on the technical side.
You know, when we were
working on this research,
we thought to ourselves,
how can we mimic real developer workflows?
And that's what you're seeing
here on this slide, right?
What are the parts of
the developer workflow
that we can imbue the agent with
so that it does work similarly
to how real developers do this work.
So, you know, starting
out by reading the docs,
understanding the current
state of a feature
before it continues to build
additional incremental changes.
You know, leaving things
cleaner than it found it.
And really what that means
at the end of the day
in practical terms is writing tests,
writing tests that it can run
on every subsequent iteration.
And that's extremely critical, right?
So leave things cleaner
than you found them.
And that also has to do with
looking for errors, right?
So what we wrote in our
system prompt is to,
and I don't mean system prompt for Claude,
I mean for this harness that we created,
to suggest that you know,
not only do you write tests
but you also write,
you also verify that there are no errors
in the browser logs.
And so leaving things cleaner
than you found them means,
hey, leaving things in a clean state
where there are no errors
for the next session,
so that when the next session starts,
it doesn't start with a
whole bunch of problems.
We do have an interesting thing here
that I do wanna highlight if
you look at the code base,
is that one of the things
that we do is I mentioned
that we've constricted the
session timeframe to one hour.
So you know, sometimes
what will happen is,
the agent will not have completed its work
by that one hour time
horizon within that session.
And so we actually have
the agent make a commit
right before the session ends,
even if it has not completed its work,
so that no matter what, if
the agent runs out of time
and gets anxious or whatever,
it still at least writes the history
and then the next agent can pick up
and clean up whatever
the previous agent left
in maybe not such a great state.
So that does happen
that it's a failure mode
if you constrict that timeframe
and it can't complete its work in time.
And then of course the final one,
which we've already said
so many times before,
test, you know, test
before declaring victory
because if you just have it write code
and not test its code,
you're not gonna get the best results.
And this is what Nadine and
I were talking about earlier,
if we ask, you know,
Claude to just one-shot,
it can produce a good outcome
but it might have surprising
failure mode, surprising bugs.
So just like we as
developers, we want the agent
to write those tests as
it continues to work.
- Yeah. So that's all.
Thank you so much guys
for attending this talk
and we hope it was valuable.
- We'll share it.
- If you're here,
we'd love for you to come
to our booth, take a look.
We'll also be sharing the QR code now,
like that I mentioned.
So there it is. So feel free to scan it.
This will give you
access to the blog post,
the architecture and also,
yeah, so a few things.
So please do scan it and
come and see us and yeah.
- Yeah. Thanks so much.
- Thank you.
- And we do have some time if,
I know we might be
breaking out a little bit
of the AV advice,
but if anybody wants to give
us a question we can take one,
but we're just gonna have to repeat it
and you're gonna have
to speak up 'cause it's,
we don't have mics.
Right.
So I mean we can go into
a lot of different paths
with your question but those
are some like, you know,
top of mind thoughts
that I wanted to offer.
- That's really helpful.
- Yeah, yeah, of course.
All right.
Well, thank you all so much and
enjoy the rest of re:Invent.
Stop by the booth. We'll be there.
We're basically for the next few days.
Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(audience applauding)